so we got a package in the mail this
might be the most random unlikely collab
that I've ever seen from Xbox they have
done some wild collabs in the past but
Xbox and OPI for those of you that don't
know OPI is a nail polish brand so I
have no idea what's inside this box but
I knew that I had to film it because
look at these freaking beautiful colors
like these are like all my favorite
colors all mixed in one so I can only
imagine what's inside of this box I'm
also a huge fan of the OPI nail polish
brand so let's open it up
oh what this looks like a creamsicle
look at these beautiful colors
[Music]
Xbox and OPI are back and turning up the
heat with a new Xbox wireless controller
sun-kissed Vibes OPI special edition
daring pastels and shocking brights from
opi's Summer make the rules collection I
like if they say sold separately so you
buy the nail polish and you can also buy
the Xbox controller dude this controller
is absolutely beautiful I love these
colors like what a cool idea so it says
again so Xbox has done this before why
am I just finding out about this
either way I'm here for it now this is
such a great color palette this is very
exciting because I just started painting
my nails again during the pandemic I
didn't I didn't paint them anymore but
now we're back
so this could not have come at a better
time this is flex on the beach this is
sanding in stilettos which is absolutely
something that you would never find me
doing but I love this color I love the
name of this one it's summer Monday
through Fridays oh okay risque this one
is called surf naked I hate to admit
that um I've actually witnessed someone
doing that there is a well-known nude
beach in San Diego there's a guy there
that just he goes for it I can't even
imagine going into like the Pacific
without having a wetsuit on like it's
freaking freezing this one's for you
dude
[Music]
I love that they used all of the colors
in the collection I mean I guess that's
kind of the point but it looks so good
[Music]
look at this oh my goodness
I love that they even did kind of like a
shiny finish so it really does kind of
pull from these nail polish colors like
this one looks like it's less metallic
so it matches the d-pad this oh my gosh
this is so cool I love the way that they
pulled in the metallic accents from this
color as well and this green is also
more of like a matte finish they even
made the Xbox logo this color green
attention to details look at that how
cool
and there we have it all four colors
with the new OPI collab controller I'm
so ready for summer
well thank you guys for watching I
probably could have made this a shorts
but I needed a little more than a minute
so it became a full YouTube video let me
know what you guys think of this and let
me know what your favorite color is and
also I would love to know if you have a
favorite Xbox collab that they've done
in the past there's even so many that I
don't even know about so I feel like
that might be something that I want to
do is do a deep dive into the history of
Xbox collabs because I know they've done
some that I probably would be like how
did I not know this see in the next
video bye
[Music]